hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play alchemy 'or al
camilla depending on what the developers
wanted but this is a demo for a Silent
Hill mod for half-life 2 now that smells
that may seem complicated but this game
has been in development for a while and
from what I've seen from the screenshot
it's got a lot of work put into it so
I'm gonna get into this game with eyes
wide open ready to take in all that
there is to see Silent Hill alchemy now
I know that a lot of you guys have been
wanting me to play Silent Hill for a
while but I've been hesitant for a few
reasons one it's it's um oh it's quite
an old game and a lot of people have
already played it I can't imagine what
value a playthrough a mine could add to
the game but that's just my own
perspective anyway so we seem to be in
some sort of an abandoned building some
diabolical demon gonna come dashing down
this dank and dusty hallway filled with
death and destruction there I say that
it doesn't know what I am gonna do to
that demonic dastardly devil yeah
alright anyway someone write all that
down someone write all that down in the
comments below
Barry put up a graphic with all that
okay oh very nice Oh anyway I gotta jump
in there it looks like a were G working
garbage disposal okay so anyway this
game is meant to emulate the feel of
style Hill games now I would know that
given that I haven't played any style
Hill games myself Oh was I supposed to
go in on these rooms Oh Phil come in oh
all right
I see a big Silent Hill fans you are
anyone in the comments below who is a
big Silent Hill fan let me know if this
is like got the right atmosphere to it
got the right exploration to it because
I know that the old Silent Hill games
and you know kind of like the old
Resident Evil games they used to be
about more exploration and ambience and
feeling the world out as opposed to
zombies but remember you know that's
that has it placed but I mean you know
not always huh I'm thinking that I was
probably supposed to walk in this first
door here oh no I was not is that what's
not all bumped up dirt hey all right sir
yeah my eyes just blew suddenly yeah
can't help okay without the heat doesn't
work so there's got to be a key one of
the earlier please I'll use other places
are locked besides dissing so tell me
your secrets
this didn't listen oh how did I miss
that I am a giant idiot who would nice
can I have that no froggy lay must be
fridge Oh flask of acid that that's good
right I I got a flask of acid okay LSD
acid or just normal acid I I didn't even
see it
alright here we go back in the old days
oh wait no I know what I need to do with
this I need to go to the lock and
dissolve it right the acid will take
care of the lock okay there we go
got it I'm outta here
am i cool I got the sudden feeling of
cry of fear which is which isn't too
weird of a thing to imagine because well
what the hell is that oh I know some
reason I feel guilty about what what do
I feel guilty about what are you talking
about why is there a big demonic symbol
on the wall that are touched uh just
like me I touched first ask questions
later if you know what I mean oh hell
worm bit lost but then again I don't
think that I'm supposed to know exactly
what's going on just yet best to go all
the way down to the bottom that's what
the answers just surely to be because if
they were at the top then they'd be far
too easy to find aha dammit lock as I
thought I suspected that it might have
been locked because I am the world's
greatest detective in that regard
flesh ooh [ __ ] is broken kid Hey
Oh oh good another symbol of satanic
succulents not good with alliteration
today oh hello this place is quite empty
now another person has left and simply
disappeared it frightens me something is
wrong with this town of my tenants only
old Andy remains he doesn't want to
abandon this town he loves to tend his
bookstore although he hasn't had a
visitor for quite a while unfortunately
doesn't have any other place to go nor
do I for that matter I fear we will die
here hold agent no one will ever know I
suppose there's no reason to keep the
apartment keys in this case anymore I'll
hide them in the wardrobe I also can't
seem to find the spare key to the main
entrance I probably lost him when I was
last with Andy okie dokie so I need to
find Andy that were you staying
and also this some reason us oh it's a
Steve point I didn't see that at first
before okay I saved all right that's
good maybe I'll manage his key wait a
minute was that the key though they were
talking about in the thing
what was that the key that would be
where were man once had nothing but
hatred and darkness pain permeated his
existence then God was born born in that
pain born of a man and a woman who put
their faith in the power of the Sun and
so God came unto earth and he gave law
and order to its people
he gave them flesh time and death thus
the people were happy or no now they
knew the value of flesh in time time
divided all into day and night night
brought the man the realm of dreams in
dreams they could build their own
paradise free of misery and despair a
paradise of happiness a paradise
well that was rather profound does it
not a lot to do is go let's going on
right now
Oh these symbols that was the fleshy
symbol do I have to I have to actuate
the symbols on the walls or old dreams
hey what about dreams my dreams your
dreams so so far seen flesh and dreams
what does that mean I honestly have no
idea okay alright then moving on I got
the old man at oh there's another one
darkness the flesh dreams in darkness oh
and God bless dreams gotten darkness did
I would oh it's just knobs I thought
that was an eye for an owl or something
last dreams got it darkness he doesn't
open I found the old manager's key but
where does that go
yeah not down there okay so it's got to
be another place upstairs or maybe now
that I've looked at all the new daddies
or flesh flesh darkness less darkness
God and beams ah no I'm trying to figure
it out just give me a second last
darkness darkened dreams dark darkness
dark Godin dreams
I'm thinking that this isn't actually
like a oh ah everybody in the comments
right now genius I am and how amazingly
I just solved that puzzle Galago me
master did that I'm the best there ever
was yep
good good good for me I did it
I'm gonna go claim my prize now damn it
what do I have how do I have an
inventory or something to look up like a
good huh there's gotta be like a shimmy
shimmy Jimmy Jimmy I've got two keys to
managers old key
and something else someone checked out
here first now it's open all right my
favorite when it's open
here's your no no it won't open okay
that's not my thing
not my favorite 20 clue okay another
puzzle huh
I need to burn them in order there's
some clue pinned a little bit of
instruction maybe can I get a clue can I
buy a vowel oh yeah I get it
I didn't everyone I'm a genious I think
a boy this game sure is good at making
the dumb people feel smart this guy all
right I did it
what did I did I know what I did okay
let's go let's go team go good job
everybody
team effort I wouldn't have done it
without you guys cheering me on in the
comments telling me how smart I am
you're writing how smart I am right
you're writing over and over how smart I
am right cuz if you're not then we have
a bit of a problem oh okay this looks
good
wait a minute is this the same place I
was before is just a new floor just same
layout locks broken one key came out
bout of the bunch oh there's someone
there would someone tell me if you were
there doors damn that's good
is it gonna burst open and a monsters
gonna pop out so what's gonna happen was
it
who's um doing Stumm okay what was that
that sounded like a piano oh this via oh
I get it I get it I get it now shut up
handle playing by itself very very
clever very uh very spooky
well what was the point of coming in
here there's got to be something in that
miss me I'm just gonna span the uski
wherever I can because sometimes I just
can't see what it wants to tell me so
I'm just gonna dam down the uski until
find something if nothing then nothing
if something then something if what's
then not but it's got to be something
it's got to be something
the can have it no reason to come in
here with therapy yes I guess not
all right let's get out of here let's
give me the creep all right one down
let's bear this one one key came up out
of the bunch all right oh good
the TV's on I'm glad that everyone
abandoned this place I wonder why
maybe because it's haunted his ball you
know how honker balls can get whoa wait
a minute
Oh
you all seen me why'd you do that down
volume a bit I'll turn it back up sorry
okay nice painting a locked box can I
open that and a letter dear Elizabeth I
can't imagine life without you I love
you my heart beats only for you and I
will wait for you forever my room is
always open to you call me and the door
will be unlocked my number is five five
five four five a four I think she's dead
bro good for you for sticking around but
she's so dead I haven't seen a save
point in a while I'm over here just
mashing my used button poking everything
as hard as I can
nothing seems to be working that's how I
approach everything in life love life
learning poke it as hard as you can
generally good strategy okay I don't see
anything else this has been life lessons
with marklar by the way I'm not sure how
long this this is a demo by the way I
think I mentioned that but this is just
a demo so this is not the full game but
I really there's been so much work but
in this style Hill aficionados what are
you saying about it this is good bad oh
is that blood what else just rust oh
these are cages
know that you these are cases for
children it's an old toy little holes
beds there's a standing up b1 what is
that is there camera in front of
meathooks
isn't that a little weird well weird
I found film inside the camera oh oh I'm
sure it will beat the light folder look
at I don't want to know what goes here
yeah me neither
his rumors are getting progressively
more disturbing okay Oh sharp
hi baby I want to get out of this room
thank you very much hot air is there
something I need
I know all right how about a baby huh
when he came up out of the bunch oh oh
I'm sure this room will be equally is
life-altering oh good I go in I don't
need to go down there do i okay what's
that oh the number up to five five five
ah I don't remember what it was I gotta
go back five eight three four maybe that
was it
five five five five eight three four not
ah okay I gotta get it cuz I gotta
unlock the door um where was it was it
over here okay no so yeah we I think was
it was it not yes yes no maybe so my
memory is failing me I'm not yeah five
high five four five eight four there was
no rien there for five eight for I
should have memorized that or five a
four five five five four five eight four
five five five four five a four now
everyone in the comments right five five
five four five eight four it'll help me
remember come on just bear with me guys
five four five four five before bah bah
bah oh four five eight 400 oh no was
that in type type like a wind I can't
remember five five five or five 84
yah-ha-ha-ha-ha I really thought that
forgot therefore Zayn no one answered
but does that mean the door will be
unlocked
oh is that wait do you guys hear that
Zuzu guys is here that hey hey okay
suppose all is jammed
all right which one of these sons of
[ __ ] was locked
that was the demon room of hellish
nightmares that I don't want to go and
do that ones lock was broken
no no what are you what do we do what do
I do the doors jammed what do I do
I hear you here are you in there do I
get to you how do I get to you ah maybe
if I go floor up I can get back there
too by going down I'm not sure I'm I'm
very confused right now
I even been on the third floor I don't
know my goodness I just so happened to
go oh right anything I feel guilty
guilty about staying behind in this
hellhole while everyone got out without
me or maybe I filled the room what okay
it's coming from above
hello I'm sorry
I'm happy with my Kurt right nightmares
who are you now who's the poor lad but
bit up here you know who's a boy yeah Oh
would you have I been II I don't
remember if I've been on this floor or
the other one Oh need the key to the box
wait is that the box that I picked up
before that okay all right why is the
bathtub caged off
hey how's fun let's never do that again
God how we do know I do all right okay I
think this is the think this is where I
started I believe um yeah that's where I
started the only thing left for me to do
is go
all right no no no I gotta go up okay
let me just Dave that's Dana single
anything oh no I can't go up all right
so what did that do
what did answering the phone do it said
that he wouldn't like unlock your door
but I don't know it's one there's so
many doors I heard the bringing from
here but no no no it must not mean that
it's coming from here if that locks
broken and I've been in every other room
here I think it must mean that there's
some door downstairs that got unlocked
at least that's what I could imagine so
as someone tell me what is the deal with
Silent Hill anyways they like some
portal the demon realm or is it like the
interphase between hell and earth I'm oh
no what is Silent Hill and actually I
think I remember reading somewhere I'm
not nothing new here I think I remember
reading somewhere that Silent Hill is
actually based off of a real town that
has dumb is next to like a coal fire a
permanent coal fun okay that's not where
I came from you know what
there are naturally occurring fires um
deep underneath the earth that where if
a mineshaft is like struck by lightning
a lightning or uh a coal vein is somehow
ignited it could burn almost perpetually
depending on how much calls available
now usually these are not common but
still it can't happen and they can burn
for like hundreds of years there's quite
a few places
oh wait I've already been here I read
did I don't know what this did but
they're like um what won't up whoa whoa
whoa won't open
what won't open would you stay it won't
open what won't open what what won't
open
you said something won't open what won't
open what this
I'm very confused okay anyway either way
it won't open that's long in the short
of it so damn it I don't know what it
meant
I must have been there must have had
some um I'm such an idiot there were so
many locked doors on the third floor of
course it would mean it was up there
then we pretty much every door was
locked
means there's got to be something up
there that I need sorry I just going on
panting little you know nervous
this game is uh good good good
one key came up out of the bunch ah so
there uh-oh oh good a party in my honor
whose honor I went out a fun time here
right before all the bad times of death
and maiming mutilation skin ripping off
the only thing I know about style is
that crappy movie that they made was it
crappy I don't know I've watched it just
remember the part with a little girl get
her in the tub oh good oh good I just
love
oh it's photography up throws the demon
thing don't know how to operate this
equipment ok I got the film I need to oh
I don't know I didn't take photography
in school ok after all the preparations
are complete you can then develop the
photograph don't forget to use only use
red light or else the negatives will
become overexposed load the film into
the drum and fill the drum with chemical
a then print the photographs on the
enlarger once printed dip the photograph
into the white tray filled with chemical
aid - afterwards dip the photo into the
blue tray containing chemical be washed
the photo in the green tray with water
finally allowed the photograph to dry
okay so put the negative in the camera
themes explanatory or self chemical 8 to
be where's uh there it is okay do I need
to fill
but hey they're gonna faces what are you
talking about oh I don't need to do it
by myself
okay it's gonna be fine got an empty
bottle I guess I fill it up with Wawa
good yeah I got a bottle water my
favorite can't wait to discover what's
on this I thought I saw something
what's on this thing going yay what a
beautiful kitty
and ladies too I guess but look at that
Kitty gun okay okay so in the camera but
ah okay in the camera huh would you
talking about are you talking about
breath breath breath breath what are you
talking about too early to use aha
Oh to breathe hey there but in there now
the image is developing in there and
then yeah where's the stain
oh the toys and a dead body that's good
that's good right there
I like that I like that a line I like
that I like that a tremendous amount so
now that I have that what was up point O
is the point who's a boy who's a boy
what's the point of that why did I need
is there some oh it's a puzzle I gotta
put the teddy bear baby and other
whatever the hell that is on the things
teddy bear baby other thing okay I got
it all right
teddy bear baby other thing teddy bear
baby other thing teddy bear been a while
since I saw teddy bear I'll know what
anyone remembers slender Elementary I
was one of my favorites I think that was
a lot of people's favorite
I heard the mouth there was some else it
was only for some reason I feel guilty
great congratulations your guiltiest
son-of-a-bitch anderson bag hey where
was it um this was pardon Mona you all
run that by me again I'll say one more
time oh look it's a low that's new when
you come from Oh
gimmick gimmick give it to me Darren
okay I don't care I don't care I don't
care don't care okay I'm Philip Philip
huh I'd be a great dad I just tell the
baby to shut up all the time
oh yeah the bunny bunny rabbit hey ma
why why am I do I didn't even need to
remember the order let's not
I thought I heard some from over here
things open things open give me gold
saucer great I got a gold saucer what
why
306 okay alright okay I'll go to 306
pounds fantastic close that today I'm
just getting a little paranoid okay just
leave me alone all right
realistic Spiro six zero six which
weighs 306 303 graphics see okay wait no
no no no Wright was was a porter at why
do I have a gold saucer Harris I know we
have a gold saucer am I gonna invite uh
some demonic Tea Party I need to be
prepared but not the teacup and T of
course just a saucer been in here this
was like the only one that was unlocked
right
it was the original one that was
unlocked okay yeah I don't need to be in
here need to get out actually this is
like the first room I came in
I don't know I don't know I've been in
here I've been the birthday I get
anything else back
oh no but what up okay I got a gold
saucer I got the golden saucer I got the
golden huh sir I've been in 305 the only
one I haven't been in is this one damn
it what what do i do I have a golden
saucer I wash it by fashion do I put it
in a garbage bin and throw it down the
chute that I don't know it's got a bad
feeling then I get always had a bad
feeling what do I do
there must be something on another floor
that I'm missing and into every place
here right I think so okay all right
I don't I got guns saucer and I know
what it means I don't know what it means
I don't have an inventory where I can
inspect items I just have oh whoa what
did I get why what did I just do oh okay
all right sorry guys I've been kind of
everywhere and I didn't think to go
there for some reason I totally forgot
about the garbage chute so I don't know
what that did exactly but I'm gonna go
find out I think it fell down a 4 below
I gotta stay guys I've been playing I
was wandering around not talking for a
while and you know I haven't just played
a horror game not talking to nobody
except you lovely people out there but
just talking to myself kind of helps
reassure me or some reason but for some
reason when I was playing just for like
five minutes there I got like the worst
I got I got chills up and down my spine
I got I saw things out of the corner my
I was not having up not having a fun
time
okay I need to find where I think the
other small box is because that would
make sense that that would do that um
was it up floor upwards it floor down I
don't remember I was just everywhere and
I don't remember where it was
oh I'm such an idiot I still don't know
what this golden saucer does but
whatever aha okay I think I found it
yeah Silver Star sir ah that helped me I
got a golden the silver saucer now I
still don't know what to do with them I
really don't I I've been literally
everywhere and I don't know what it
wants from me I really don't know I've
got a golden a silver saucer what the
hell do you want
Oh
oh-oh-oh
hello is that there I got a room key god
oh my god I've been wandering around for
a bit for that one the only other ah
haha hey I did it
Klaus quick at least I didn't have to go
far I've been wandering around a while
guys it's not been fun weird noises have
been happening I haven't been crying
what are you talking about yeah so I got
what I needed I think I don't know how
long I been here the Sun doesn't shine
in this place this room curved it
disappered I'm locked in this small
court ride or I tried to make a hole but
tame the Andy's room but I'm too weak
and don't have the energy if I stay much
longer
I will wildest a / - okay so either this
is a little kid somebody's not too
bright yea-ah
Oh Oh why's it he says it changed
oh oh no oh no oh no oh no what are you
okay no no
okay
okay alright there you have it
that was alchemy hahahahahahaha that was
really good good you don't even
understand most of my fear from that
came when I wasn't talking which was
really cool and I was like wandering
around for about ten minutes just by
myself and I felt so lonely I'm not
lonely but alone you know it's weird
when I'm talking cuz I imagine that you
guys are listening but when I'm not
talking cuz it's me
is dimly lit room just me nobody and
maybe whatever monstrosity lives in my
closet but either way that was fantastic
that was incredibly well made I mean it
was I've never played a Silent Hill
before in my life but if that's what
it's like then I will pretty damn
awesome I mean you guys got to play for
yourself the demo is totally free right
now it takes some finagling to get it to
work you got install like the source
developer kit and whatnot but holy crap
that was amazing go check out the
website for the development
I think it's on ModDB I think that's it
but either way that was phenomenal guys
you don't even realize I had so much fun
playing that there was so spine-tingling
and I didn't even see a single monster
it is the perfection of atmosphere who's
not providing once they prepare I'm
being a little I'm being a little
ecstatic right now but that was
fantastic atmosphere something that
games today are severely lacking and I
meant this to be well it's gonna be one
part anyway now but I meant this to be I
didn't know drun this long but hey enjoy
the extra-long episode today guys thank
you guys so much for watching and as
always I will see you
Oh
ha